according to Einstein's theory of
general relativity I'm in space are
inseparable that's why the term
space-time exists base time itself is
distorted via objects with mass like
dark matter black holes planets or even
Stars this creates a bubble in
space-time that creates what we call
gravity disparities in gravity and
velocity create something called time
dilation and a simple way to give you an
example of this is from the film
Interstellar the gravitational pull on a
planet that is near a large black hole
compared to the pole of Earth's gravity
to the sun is so much stronger that time
is actually slowed down every hour they
spent on the planet near the black hole
would be seven years back on Earth
that's relativity folks Beyond Time
could simply mean that time dilation
exists and is created by the tornado in
faramezula acting as a sort of black
hole for example